hello everyone and welcome back to the
capablanca saga now at the last video we
left off in the match josé raúl
capablanca vs. 1/4 the cuban champion
and the the thirteen-year-old kappa
blanka was able to win that match it was
quite an accomplishment and after that
feet the entire cuba started knowing who
Jose world kappa blanka was and i
thought that we were going gonna go from
there that was 1901 straight to 1911 -
couple uncas first a big international
tournament in san sebastian in spain
where he faced off against well some of
some of the old legends and some of the
new upcoming stars like Akiba Rubinstein
and a little Spillman and such but I
decided that it wouldn't be fair to go
there before we check out the match
against Frank Marshall as this was the
this was a basically cup of Uncas
tickets to the big international
tournament in San Sebastian and it's a
very controversial match
there is a lot of controversy behind it
so I do I do hope I managed to cover it
all briefly but before we start the
match a cup of Lanka vs. Marshall I
would just like to share a very nice
story all right couple Monica mentions
it in his book my chess career after the
match with one course so he says that he
who once visited the chess club and then
there there were the these two gentlemen
playing chess elderly gentlemen as he
put it and he was just sitting there and
he was watching them play for four maybe
hours I don't know and then one of the
gentlemen had to leave and then the
other gentleman said that
capablanca does he know how to play
chess
a couple of Lanka said yes but up
student up until that point he never
said a word he just you know said there
and watched them play and the first the
elderly gentleman to offer a cup of
lanka a full night as odd Saka Blancas
accepted and the game was over very
quickly kappa blanka won that game and
the gentleman then said okay i guess i
can to beat you with a night odds i will
give you a lesser odds i will give you
the odds of a pawn then kappa blanka won
that game as well and then the other
lieutenant said
okay we're gonna play it even odds then
Capablanca won the first game then the
elderly gentleman said it oh I probably
got too tired by playing so long with my
friend but then they played the second
game capablanca won that game as well
and that the nd elderly gentleman said
that he was a most likely ill that's
what he's losing so much and capablanca
says that by the time he won the third
game that there was no disease in the
world that the elderly gentleman was not
suffering from and then our capablanca
said to the elderly gentleman would you
like me to give you the odds of a night
and then well of course the gentleman
was quite offended but he did accept and
that game was a real struggle but
capablanca was able to win that game he
said that well he was very angry and
that the gentleman was about to leave
but before he left he asked capablanca
what was his name and then the Kuban
answered that his name was Jose raúl
capablanca
and then he said that the elderly
gentleman was relieved as he knew who
the boy was and that he couldn't believe
his eyes that such a small board kid
could play such strong chess so one
interesting story I do hope you enjoyed
that and also capablanca mentions that
when he started preparing for his
Columbia College that he went to the
United States he he needed to learn
English he didn't know some English but
he needed to of course perfected that
one day that he was in the Manhattan
Chess Club he was already known as the
strongest player in the Manhattan chess
club and that Emanuel asker visited the
Chess Club and a kebab Lanka said that
he was very pleased that Lasker asked
about a cup of wine if he was interested
in looking at one of the depositions the
last girl was interested in and then
human Capablanca sat down and then
capablanca says that a person came
through the door also in the Manhattan
Chess Club and that he sat down and
started explaining at the position to
Capablanca in Los Kerr and the couple
Blanca was very interested in this he
was well he was amazed by this as both
him and Lasker were listening to this
gentleman and capablanca couldn't
believe I mean who is this gentleman
that's explaining things to me and also
to the world champion Emanuel asker he
said he must be some super-strong
Lasker's friend and then after he was
finished explaining Lasker said that ok
that's not really it
then Lasker explained what the position
was really about and then the gentleman
said ok and he just left and then
Capablanca asked Oskar like who's your
who's your super-strong friend and
Lasker replied I have no idea I I
thought he was your friend and then
kappa blanka and Lasker were both very
much amazed how both of them were
treating the gentleman with much respect
as both of them thought that he was the
other guy's friend but a lot of
interesting stuff getting back to this
match I do hope you enjoyed the little
stories even though some of you are not
interested in any stories but I am I'm
sorry about that but it's just the way
it is but getting back to this match the
match was played in 1909 and it was
played in in a lot of venues I believe 7
different venues the first the match
started in New York so then a lot of the
venues were changed and then the match
ended also in New York I will put a bit
about the match in the description below
and also I'll link to the page where you
can check out something more about this
match now for those of you who are into
chess history or in the chest overall
you probably have heard of Frank
Marshall and his uh well I believe we
can say that it is his immortal game his
American Beauty if you haven't seen it I
didn't make a video about it um more
than a year ago I will put a link to it
in the description below if you want to
check out that game just to give you a
sense what kind of a player Frank
Marshall is he's a very fierce attacking
player and he was known to be the
strongest player in the United States so
this game by the time this game was
played he wasn't he was not a US
Champion u.s. champion was a Harry
Nelson Pillsbury but Pillsbury died in
1906 so for three years now at the
United States are without a champion and
basically what the organizers tried to
do with this match is the verify that
Frank Marshall is indeed the person who
should be the next US Champion and they
are basically using Kosovo Capablanca
as well perhaps not as a punching bag
but as something that would prove that
Frank Marshall is the strongest player
in the United States this is one of the
games Capablanca himself has chosen in
his book my chest career so I do hope
you enjoy it and we're gonna cover a bit
more stories about this match but first
we're gonna check up on some of the
games I didn't I have not yet decided
which which of the games were gonna show
but we are going to show at least three
games from this match the match was
organized as first eight wins and the
draws are not counting so if you
remember in the concourse over scope of
Lanka it was first the four wins here it
is first the eight wins in this game so
this is Game five kappa blanka already
won one game three games were drawn so
capablanca is already leading in this
match and i we will of course not be
showing the entire match as the entire
match lasts for 23 games but it's really
an exciting match and it's like I said
it holds a lot of controversy and it's
it's a really important match for for a
cup of Blanca and his further career as
this is the chance for Marshall to prove
that he is the rightful heir to the US
Championship throne but also took up a
bunker to prove himself to the entire
world as the Frank Marshall in those
days was considered to be one of the
let's say one of the 10 strongest
players in the world so let's see this
very nice game Marshall has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 and
Capablanca also mentions in his book
that even though from the time he played
that match against one core so in 1901
seven years have passed or eight this is
1909 so I guess 8 years he still haven't
studied any chess theory he says the
only chest Theory he studied on openings
was an analysis by Manuel Lasker of a
certain line in the rule opposites I
don't know if you've ever seen it after
sorry after Bishop to b5 where black
goes f5 it's the youngish gambit I once
actually tried this you know in a
classical game I was able to draw in the
game I guess against again the master
but you know I did
enjoy too much I don't think anyone
actually plays it today but yeah this is
the only piece of theory kappa blanka
read by manuel last round he said that
it wasn't all that great as last we made
some mistakes in it by the way d4 by
frank marshall we have d5 by Capablanca
c4
so we have the queen's gambit on the
board east 6 we have Knight to c3 and
now comes Knight to f6 so we have the
Queens gambit declined Bishop to g5 and
now comes Bishop to e7 everything is
alright here we have III and now comes
night to eat before although capablanca
says that by the time he was writing his
book that he he wouldn't really play
nice TV for now
but as then he didn't know any theory he
just he said that he overheard someone
mentioned some time ago that Alaska at
one point played this move against
Marshall so he decided to adopt it and
okay Bishop character Sonny 7 Queen
captures Sonny 7 and now comes Bishop to
d3 here kappa blanka says that he would
prefer something like capturing an d5
and after captures Queen b3 to pressure
the d5 pawn and also hindered White's
development of the light square bishop
as the Queen is also pressuring b7 but
ok Frank Marshall has a different
playing style he's a very aggressive
player we have Bishop to d3 Knight
captures on c3 be captures on c3 and now
comes Knight to d7 and ok Knight to f3
we have castles by Capablanca and now
Queen to c2 pressuring the h7 pawn h6
not allowing the h7 point to be a target
and also taking away the g5 square from
Marshalls night we have castles by
Marshall and now comes c5 Capablanca
knows that there is a big attack coming
on the King set so he wants to transfer
the game in the center and also to the
Queen side rook F to e 1 and now D
captures on c4 Bishop captures on c4 and
now b6 capablanca allows the Queen to e4
for his rook to be under attack he but
as the Marvel does play this Capablanca
says that he's not very happy about this
from Marshalls perspective as okay you
are threatening the rook Bishop to d3
I will threaten Queen to h7 but it's way
too slow to play like this s kappa
blanka says he says that the only thing
this Queen to e4 move does is help kappa
blanka
bring his pieces to the squares that he
was going to bring them anyway only this
way a white is playing into black's hand
but okay rook to b8 getting the room to
safety Bishop to d3 Marshall now
threatens checkmate and now comes Knight
back to f6 attacking couple Blancas
Queen we have cling to a four and now
Bishop to b7 putting the bishop to this
very strong diagonal efore we have rook
F to d8 and now comes Luke a to d1
now all of Marshalls pieces are fully
mobilized we have rook beat to c8 and
couple of Marcus's that by the time he
reached this position that his position
is just better White has no serious
threat and the blacks pieces are on more
ideal squares but okay Roop to e3
Capablanca doesn't like this move that
Marshall played he says that Bishop the
b1 immediately would have been much
better as after Luke to e3 was played we
have seek after sandy four by Capablanca
C chapters on d4 and now rook to c3
which would not be possible in the line
in the line that kappa blanka suggested
here marshall plays and this move now
but here bishop to be one is a weaker
move Capablanca says that g5 is a pretty
big threat after this Bishop to be one
so the the best line would be Queen to
h4 as now this g5 will not be a problem
after g5 you can go Knight captures on
g5 and after H capture screen captures
and g5 with check after King to f8 now
you get Queen to h6 check and now you
cannot go to the G file because of rook
to g3 and of course if King here then
Bishop b5 check picks up the rook this
is the problem but after this rook the
c3 move a Marshall first plays Bishop to
b1 and now it's a different story
now couple bunkers move is way stronger
as there is always this threat of the
in-between rook captures on e3
Capablanca played the g5 the Queen is
under attack and here we have Queen to
g3
there is no point in sacrificing the
night for the poor now because black can
always capture on III first and only
then react to this threat but okay we
have night captures on g5 this was
played in the game
rook captures on e3 first by Capablanca
and now Queen captures on e3 and now
comes Knight to g4 kappa blanka can also
capture the knight immediately but first
he wants to stabilize everything ninth
to g4 attacking the Queen Queen to g3
and now comes Queen captures on g5 we
have h4 the queen is under attack
Queen to g7 and now Queen to c7
attacking the bishop here and here kappa
blanka played rook captures on d4 and
this is a something couple blanca also
mentions in his book he says that it's a
very it's very dangerous for someone to
analyze games of great masters not not
just couple Blancas games but games of
other great masters because here
everyone prays Capablanca for this move
rook captures on d4 and that his game
was perfect but later after the pinnacle
Blanca mentions that it's not that great
of a move that white gets comfortable
after this move that Queen to f6 would
have been just a much better move you're
already threatening Queen captures on f2
the queen is defending the rook so
there's not much danger here of course
is the bishop cannot be captured because
of Queen captures an f2 white would most
likely have to retreat and then black is
just better but okay
Queen to see we have rook after Sun
before this was played in the game as
Capablanca never spends too much time
calculating lines Queen to b8
check this is the problem where white
gets gets counter play now you cannot
block with the Queen because the Queen
has to keep an eye on the rook on d4 so
King to h7 is played here and now not
capturing the bishop but rather a 5
check checking the King and also not
allowing the Queen to keep an eye on the
rook the pawn is now in the way so the
rook captures rook is a threat here but
there's not much you can do here
Bishop to e4 is played at least blocking
not allowing the bishop to stay a target
on b7 rook captures on d4 and now Bishop
captures on b1 and now kappa blanka
still
a knight a bishop in the night for a
rook but white will grab a lot of pawns
as counterplay queen capture sunday 7
we have night captures on e5 and now
comes Luke to f4 and here we have a just
a beautiful move where you definitely
want to pause the video and try to find
the move Capablanca played it's really a
really a wonderful idea and I'm sure
gonna enjoy it
so I will give you a couple of seconds
as usual you know while I have a nice
sip of my water for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations it's
truly an amazing move to find and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
Bishop to e4 it's really a wild move
you're already threatening checkmate so
that's that's a pretty big threat of
course and the reason why you cannot
capture the bishop is next Knight to f3
check and now of course the pawn is
pinned you cannot capture the night if
King to h1 you cannot go to h2 that's
also covered by the knight if King gauge
one Queen to a-1 is checkmate
that's that's beautiful of course after
roblox I know that many of you like to
say that in the comments and another
idea after Knight to f3 check if you go
to f1 then simply Knightly to check
picks up the rook on e4 Knight that King
goes back Knight captures here and then
black is up a piece completely winning
so Bishop to b4 a deadly move marshal
blocks this we have g3 and now comes
Knight f3 trick interestingly couple of
Lanka says oh I could have played a much
better mood than this Knight to f3 I
should have played f5 but the engine
actually agrees with capablanca so even
though capablanca says that he didn't
play a good move the engine agrees with
Capablanca we have King G 2 and now the
reason wake up from Lanka said that he
most likely didn't agree with this
because he didn't play Knight captures
on h4 now with check with which he
should have played it's a double check
from the knight and the bishop and then
after king moves king h3 now you can
just go back and you still cannot
capture the bishop because Knight g5
check picks up the rook but ok we still
always return to this that even though
Capablanca was
more than able to calculate anything he
was well often rather lazy to calculate
f5 and now defending the bishop and now
Queen captures and b6 grabbing yet
another pawn now comes Knight to h4 a
double check King to h2 and now you
can't go anywhere and on the last rank
because Queen 2 a1 check would still be
a huge problem and now Knight back to f3
with check rook captures on f3 Bishop
captures on f3 and now Queen to e6 and
now you can see that black is up a
bishop but white is up a pawn it's a
passed an outside past a pawn and
although black is better a black still
has to be very careful Bishop 3 for
protecting his f5 pawn we have f3 now
trying to give up the f3 pawn for the f5
pawn which would allow White's to
deliver many more checks and also would
pick up the bishop on f3 Bishop to d3
now and now Queen to d5 again attacking
the bishop Queen to be to check King to
g1 and now Russia back to B 1 and we
have a4 white starts pushing just passed
pawn and now Queen to a1 Queen - b7
check we have King to g6 Queen to b6
check King to h5 now trying to hide the
King here and now King to h2 bla
why doesn't allow any discovered checks
and it's interesting that now although
capablanca could have played a few
better moves throughout the game now
that he is in the endgame where he is
slightly better he will play this with
with engine like precision brush up to
82 first you cannot capture the pawn as
the bishop is hanging in first Bishop to
a 2 now comes the Queen to b5 attacking
the f5 pawn and now King to g6 defending
we have a 5 and now Queen to d4 we have
Queen to see sex with check King Queen
box would have 6 and now comes Queen to
e8 with check if you try to Queen
captures on f6 it's very important to
point out that after King captures a 6
black is in time to stop this special d5
you will play a for not a lot of fun
capture and now the pond Queens on a
light square so you will never be able
to do this so after Queen to f6 we have
Queen to 8
check Queen to f7 blocking now comes the
Queen to a for attacking the bishop and
preparing to pull the past born Queen to
e6 now preparing to defend the the Queen
Square but also preparing to deliver
check here we have a six now comes Queen
2e to check King to h3 and here comes
Bishop to d5 black a white continues
pushing his passport we have a seven and
now what do you do here the problem is
if you play Queen captures on f3 which
seems like a reasonable idea you protect
the eight square twice then you will
suffer a lot of checks here Queenie
eight checking g5 27 checking gauge five
Queenie eight check King g5 Queen d8
checking goes back Queenie a check and
it's hard to say if black will be able
perhaps to hide away from checks most
likely but still it's a king on an open
board you don't want to allow this here
after a seven capablanca didn't capture
with the Queen he played Bishop captures
on f3 and it was in this position on
mole 52 that Frank James Marshall
resigned the game and he is now already
two two two two zero down in this match
what if you resign well whatever you do
here it doesn't really work let's say
you bring a queen into the game but
there's nothing much better you can do
the bishop here protects c6 square so
Queen cannot deliver check on c6 and
also the Queen guards yet so you cannot
deliver check on e8 you can bring a
queen into the game but it won't help
you here either Queen f1 or queen g2
let's say queen g2 King moves Queen h1
is checkmate and there is no no no
escaping that whatever whatever why does
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it a bit of a longer video but
it's a it's a really important match and
I did like to mention a couple of
stories I hope you enjoyed that for
those of you who actually watch the
videos until the end and we are gonna
cover I said at least three games but
maybe more from this match as it's a
really important match for couple Lanka
and his career and his first big
international tournament in San
sebastián Spain but we're gonna get back
to that it's really
you know I know it's chess but it's a
really juicy story so you know stay put
I would like to thank John Roberts John
Roberts the bus lift a Nega sebastian's
miss love ski Dexter Williams and
Santosh Kumar a starter man
Saravanan for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here a thing called
for watching and I will see you soon
with some more capablanca content
continuing the song of course thank you
all and I will see you soon have an
excellent week